-It is great to see you, bud.
-Happy to be here.
-Welcome back to the show.
And before we get into this,
I want to congratulate you.
You have two little
babies now, right?
-Two little babies, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Congratulations.
-Yeah, the last time
I was on Broadway, it was
a little different schedule.
I didn't have -- you know,
I wasn't waking up so early
the last time, yeah.
-Exactly.
Yeah, it's a little --
Is it much tougher now?
-It's a little tougher now.
Yeah, but it's worth it.
-What do the kids
think of daddy acting?
-Oh, my daughter loves it.
My son? He's only 2.
I have a 6-year-old
and a 2-year-old.
But Lucy's seen the show
a handful of times,
and she loves it.
She wants to come every weekend.
But the first time
she saw it, she saw me --
I have to kiss
another woman in the show,
and the whole cast
was watching for her reaction.
And she -- you know,
she was just properly horrified.
She thought I was ending
my marriage,
you know, in front of her.
Just ruining our family
right in front
of her little face.
-Oh, no! Oh, my God.
-Yeah, it was very funny.
-You know, I think about you
more than you know, because I --
[ Laughter ]
-Because I saw you
in "Hamilton," and, gosh,
you were unbelievable
in that job.
You know that.
You won the Tony Award.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're the first face --
the first person to say
anything in the whole show.
You start the whole show off.
You -- like, when
that curtain opened,
it's just you,
and I think about that.
I go, that's so much pressure.
And I've seen you
do it three times --
I'm lucky enough
to see you do it three times --
and you nail it
every single time.
You are amazing.
Do you like that pressure?
-Yeah.
I was thinking about you
when I was doing that.
[ Laughter ]
-You were thinking about me?
-Yeah.
-Wow.
-No, I -- I -- I do.
I just loved -- I loved
what Lin had written so much.
The only reason
to come to the theater
is for tremendous writing.
You know, writing is king
in the theater,
and I couldn't have found
a better piece
than "Hamilton" at that time.
I couldn't have found
a better piece
than Mr. Davis's
"Purlie Victorious."
At this time,
it's so extraordinary.
And so that's what gives me the
confidence to get out there.
It's not 'cause I'm so great.
It's because these great writers
are so great.
-I don't know.
You're pretty great, buddy.
[ Laughter ]
I have a picture of you
and your Tony Award here.
Come on, now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-They don't give these out
to everybody, bud.
They don't give this
to everybody.
You crushed it.
-Thanks.
-I wanted to ask you because
I think last month I saw you.
You did a thing,
Broadway for Biden.
And the President
was there watching.
And you teamed up
with Lin again.
-Yeah.
It was the first time
we've sung together
in about seven years.
You know, we're only like,
two years away
from the 10-year
anniversary of "Hamilton,"
the "Hamilton" premiere
downtown.
You know, you came downtown
and just really gave us
such a boost.
You know, you came
on the show
and you told the world
about this show that you'd seen.
-Because Questlove told me
that it was at a public.
Right?
-Yeah.
-And Quest was like,
"You gotta go see this play,"
and I was like, "All right."
And then, we went,
and I went with my wife,
and she was like,
"I don't understand the rapping
about Alexander Hamilton."
I go, "I don't know."
And, dude, we were crying
after your first thing.
I was like, "This was
the greatest thing I ever saw."
-Yeah.
-And that's 10 years ago?
-10 years, bro.
-Oh, my God.
-Yeah. So we got together
for for a good cause,
to raise some money
for the President.
-Do you get nervous
around the President or...?
-Terrified, but...
[ Laughter ]
-But you also performed in front
of Obama and Michelle Obama.
-That was -- that was
the most meaningful --
It wasn't --
The Tony night was great.
Grammy night was great.
But performing as an actor,
you know what I mean?
Like, this is sometimes
a silly profession,
you know, let's be honest.
[ Laughter ]
But, you know, that
it can be raised to that level
that the leader
of the free world could make --
you know, clear his schedule
for 45 minutes,
that we might do something that
he thought was important enough
to make time, you know,
it was just, um...
It was like --
I just think, like,
that's what's possible,
you know, every now and again,
when you're part of something
like that.
-Anything's possible, yeah.
Since "Hamilton,"
you've just been nonstop.
One of the hardest-working men
in show business.
You're so talented.
You have a new album
coming out November 17th.
-Yes, sir.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But this one -- this one
is called "When a Crooner Dies"
is the name of this album.
Is this your fifth
or sixth album?
-This is my fifth album.
-You have five albums, bud.
-I do, yeah.
You know, most of the ones
that people know about
are the Christmas ones.
But this is --
[ Laughter ]
This is --
I love those, too,
but this is all original music.
It's deeply personal,
the most personal one.
You know, when I started
making albums,
my producer,
my best friend, my brother,
he told me,
"You know, at some point,
I don't want you to have
any more secrets.
I want you to whisper those
secrets onto these records."
And so, yeah, it's been --
it's been a really
wonderful thing
having this outlet,
you know,
to be vulnerable and honest.
-How do you
get the time to do all of it
and have kids
and be on Broadway?
I mean, this is --
And get rave reviews.
I mean, congrats,
the play is doing great.
You actually have
a little good news
you can share
with the audience.
-Yes. You know, theater is
still making its way back.
You know, I believe
in a healthy,
thriving American theater
for the good of our nation,
you know?
And so, this play
is doing so well,
it's gotten such great response,
we are extending
an additional month.
We will be at the Music Box
until February the 4th.
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Please buy a ticket.
-Go check this out.
What do people --
what do people --
What should they know
about "Purlie Victorious"?
-Well, number one,
that it was written
by a great American,
Mr. Ossie Davis.
You know, he's like --
[ Applause ]
Yeah, I mean --
-Yeah.
You know, when you think about
legendary, inspiring theatricals
and writers and orators
in this country, you know,
Ossie's got to be on your list.
And he wrote this play.
It hasn't been on Broadway
since 1962.
And it's -- it's about America.
I think about Lin a lot
when I think about Mr. Davis,
you know, these young men
writing about their country,
what it means,
what America means,
what America meant to them.
And it's a -- it's a really
surprisingly patriotic,
joyful, moving experience.
-Yeah.
Congratulations on this.
And I'm going to check you out.
I'm just surprising you.
And you'll see my reaction
when you kiss --
when you kiss that person.
Be like -- [ Gasps ]
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Leslie Odom Jr., everybody.
"Purlie Victorious"
is on Broadway right now.
For tickets, go to
purlievictorious.com.